welcome back to the ice coffee hour with
uh me jeremy and uh obviously you guys
know graham and jack and i'm guessing
you guys have made 333
333.33 from this podcast in its eternity
is that accurate no dang
it's about half that it's actually
almost exactly half that yeah we made
165
700 from ad revenue so far wow i really
thought it was higher you guys have been
doing this for a long time and this is
your fourth time coming on is it the
fourth i think it's the fourth it could
be fifth or sixth honestly i've it's
been so many times i know i went at
least when you guys are in california at
least twice
and i know we've done at least twice out
here so i'm thinking this is probably
number five or maybe number six yeah
ever it would have been funny had you
introduced this to uh welcome back to
another episode of millennial my way and
be like oh wait
wrong [ __ ]
wrong channel i knew we didn't have it
because we don't have the candles set up
here like we've had for millennial money
lately so science oh seance we need
those for this market so
yeah for those that don't know
you are a stock market investor you have
a youtube channel with now almost 800
000 subscribers not just a youtube
channel 700 it's multiple youtube
channels rounded up you have three
youtube channels you talked about
investing growing your wealth personal
finance and uh you're a member of
millennial money yes yes so i'm i'm
happy to be here and uh yeah as far as
me i mostly focus on buying the dip in
stocks as you guys know and that's uh
what i preach on the channel all the
time we talk stocks all the time it used
to be a little more other finance but
now i just stock stock stocks every day
so um that's what i enjoy and right now
we got a fun time in the market it's a
lot of volatility everybody's wondering
are we going for a crash a recession
everything like that so to make it for
some good content i'm having the most
fun let me let me say this i'm actually
the most
uh in the best place i've ever been when
it comes to youtube videos right now i
am uh feeling great i'm so energized to
make content right now and believe it or
not last year at this time when the
market was doing great and you had you
know everybody getting excited
uh that was a time period i actually
didn't like uh for youtube content right
now i'm like having so much fun like i
look forward to making two three videos
a day it's it's a blast it's just
there's a lot of drama it's interesting
the higher your portfolio goes the less
motivation you have on youtube and when
it flips then all of a sudden you're
trying to get through let's go back the
worse your portfolio does the better you
do on youtube i know well last year a
lot of valuations got insane and so that
made it for like i i stopped even buying
a lot of stocks like in the stocks i was
buying uh late in 2020 and in 2021 the
first part of it walgreens jp morgan
like the most boring stocks out there
right now i look at a market where
there's deals all over the place and so
that to me that signal's fun um so i
think that's why i'm having a good time
on youtube like last year at this time i
was thinking about quitting i was
legitimizing your thing about what you
did jeremy was going down to like one
video a week yeah didn't you go a while
on your for your main channel without
posting for a while yeah i don't think i
post on the main channel for like two
months or at least a month maybe a month
or two and uh yeah i was just really
getting demotivated by the market and
the euphoria in the market and uh you
know every stock was gonna 10x and these
sorts of things and so uh you know we're
in the complete opposite of that market
now and so i think that's what's created
um a situation that i'm actually
enjoying it more did you feel left out
back then that everyone else was kind of
picking these stocks that were doubling
and tripling and you're you know sitting
on the sidelines kind of like missing
out of that rally yeah i mean i had a
lot of obviously i've always had a lot
of money in the market so i was still
participating but i wasn't participating
in those uh let's call them sketchy
stocks or those sorts of stocks that
were like had no business models that
were thriving during that time so i
never really feel bad at a particular
time like that or even a market like
we're in right now where things are down
trending and you buy stock and then it's
like it just went lower it just went
lower um i never try to let that affect
kind of my mentality because if you do
you're gonna end up making worse
decisions in the end if you're going to
start feeling fomo in a fomo market or
you'll start end up panic selling in
this sort of market so i tried my best
just to not to not let it affect me at
this point does it have any emotional
effect when you see like you know
hundreds of thousands of dollars of
swings in your portfolio each day i
would say no actually believe it or not
no um
i think i've just been doing it so long
i think that's the thing i've been doing
it for so long and it's it's always been
like a gradual rise for me and so
because i've been doing it for so long
i just not even really phased by it it's
like if the market's down i don't know
five percent tomorrow it's like okay
cool i'll buy some stocks um but in
terms of me getting hot you know highs
or lows off of that
not anymore so um but i'm sure there was
time periods in my life when i was an
earlier investor it felt really good now
if i hit a new milestone it's like you
know yeah but what about a lot of the
stocks that you've picked uh tattooed
chef planet 13 smile direct
uh corsair a lot of those those stocks
that you that you invested in have gone
down a lot substantially how does that
affect you mentally to see those
declines and then think that like we're
we're you know trading at a good value
and then they drop even further and
you're like well i bought more but it
drops even more yeah so first thing i
try to go back to is what's going on
with the underlying fundamentals of the
company so i look at it and i'm like
okay what's the f what's going on with
tattoo chef's actual business and is
that being reflected in the stock price
that's the first thing i focus on or
honest or whatever right and so that's
why i do a lot of channel checks and
sometimes people laugh at me like i go
to target stores several times a week
here in vegas driving around the target
stores literally i spend hours out of my
week driving a target store is going to
see tattooed chef items i go to sam's
club costco all these different stores
yeah i know it sounds absolutely
ridiculous uh you know unless you're
really like into this stuff i check out
the honest section we take pictures and
what are you looking for i'm looking for
uh seeing like new skus coming in so
right now uh tattoo chef's getting more
skews into the target which a skew is
essentially a new product so right now
they're getting more products more shelf
space which is like a huge imaginative
sitting there like out front of the
segment be like hey you should buy some
tattooed chef he's just trying to like
sell it out just throw it in people's
hearts as they walk by
like that he's trying to get some items
off the shelf there
there was uh so uh this is probably two
weeks ago i was at a target store and uh
there was a female she was looking at
the tattoo chef stuff and
i stood in the freezer aisle i kid you
not
for five minutes waiting for her to
hopefully make a decision i pretended i
was looking at something else just
standing there like
you know like enough away that i
wouldn't like spook her and she wouldn't
she wouldn't make a decision and finally
i was like i don't have the time to like
continue to stand here so i wouldn't
went somewhere else you didn't mention
anything talk to her uh because i wanted
i didn't want to mess it up i didn't
wanna i was like maybe she's gonna well
maybe she was gonna buy one she was
looking so intensely at the everything
you had you had to see if it had enough
natural appeal right yeah yeah and i was
like you know so i never know if she
actually bought or not but i was i
imagine that five minutes does meet
kevin's wife
she's like should i buy the tattooed
chef oh no wait uh no
kevin doesn't eat that
oh gosh but but you know what why
wouldn't you have gone up to her uh as
she was walking away and be like hey saw
you looking at the tattooed chef uh i'm
invested in the company can i ask you
like why you didn't want to buy it
that's something creepy no it wouldn't i
don't know i feel like standing and
staring at a lady fighting
her okay i got a good peripheral vision
maybe she was gonna walk in your
position yeah freaked out and she was so
freaked out she's like i'll just keep
looking at the stat dude
yeah i'm not gonna go buy the broccoli
over near this creepy man like i'll just
keep any sudden movements i'm just gonna
like wait here for him to leave and you
didn't leave she's like all right i'm
gonna slowly exit imagine she owns the
stock of whatever company i was
pretending to look at and she's like is
that guy ever gonna make it
i need to look at something too oh yeah
i wanna talk to her and figured out why
she didn't make the purchase or like
what it was about the packaging or like
the pricing did she take it out of the
freezer and like look at it she looked
at several while i was there she would
like take it out like look at it like
how old is she uh i would say probably
thirties i don't know
yeah i would imagine someone like in
their seventies is seven
it wasn't an easy sell right and that's
a problem isn't it well hey i'm not
going to make my judgments off of one
lady that was in an aisle for five
minutes but uh it was interesting to see
she was at least looking at the product
i don't know but uh anyway so tracking
sell through to get back to that uh
seeing like if things are running out in
those sorts of things and we even do
things like we'll count how many items
they have and then go back a day later
and see how many items they have oh they
have 11. you do that or do you send
someone uh
i won't usually go to that extent but we
do have people in the private stock
group that do that they'll count it
they'll go back the next day and they'll
be like oh there was 11 of these
you know yesterday now they're six or
now there's eight how is that how is
that at all like i feel like it's only
relevant when you compare it to other
like it's competitors right but you have
to do that like across the country you
can't just do like one grocery store who
happens to be in one location from one
person as with all things in the stock
market it's not a perfect science and
you can't just say this one thing is
going to determine whether this is a
successful investment or not i just say
like your roi from doing that is
probably pretty low i know you could do
anything else and probably make more
money than that ah that's what you could
say but
it's about putting in the work it's
about putting in the work okay and the
more work you put in maybe the the
universe gives it to you back you know
and maybe helps you out a little bit so
i don't know yeah
but that that's that's what i spent part
of my day doing but first i'd like to
thank our sponsor storyblocks alex
you're editing lately has been fantastic
you must be putting in a lot of hours
thanks man i love spending countless
hours finding the perfect b-roll for my
favorite boss
little does jack know i spend barely any
time looking for b-roll because i have
story blocks first of all alex i can
hear you cause i'm right here and second
of all what's storyblocks storyblocks is
a subscription service that actually
gives you instant access to millions of
royalty-free hd and 4k footage templates
images sound effects you name it and
finding the right piece of b-roll such
as this is one of the most challenging
time-consuming and crucial parts about
being an editor but with storyblocks
that's no longer an issue investing is a
huge part of our job and one of the best
investments i've made is storyblocks the
time and energy i save on top of the
increased quality of content is truly
priceless and best of all storyblocks
has affordable and scalable pricing
plans you can start creating with the
tools that you need without having to
worry about a budget plus their
unlimited all access plan lets you
download unlimited assets from all three
of their libraries creativity really
doesn't have to be so taxing and you
know how much i hate taxes
so take your editing to the next level
by going to storyblocks.com
ich once again guys storyblocks.com
ich we have a link down in the
description thank you so much
storyblocks for sponsoring this episode
and back to the podcast but as far as
prices declining how does that impact
you do you ever get worried to the point
where it's like well like what if this
is the new normal what if it stays like
this for 10 years or it just keeps
declining or
i worry about i worry about the the
overall economy you know like if we were
to go into a massive recession that was
a multi-year recession or something like
that that's usually my worry if we're in
a good economic climate um you know i'm
not very very worried let's put it that
way
especially for any of these sorts of
stocks that i own they can only trade
unsustainably low levels for so long you
know it can last for months or
maybe even a year but it's unsustainable
and just like last year at this time um
you know stocks got to very
unsustainable levels like p e ratios
reached like you know parabolic levels
and things like that and if you looked
at like a forward pe uh through like
your indiana research or whatever you
looked at forward ps of uh you know
small cap stocks or large caps or mid
caps they were trading astronomically
high at this time last year it was
unsustainable and right now if you look
they're trading at their lowest levels
they have in over a decade
over a decade for mids and small caps
and so when i look at that that makes me
feel pretty darn comfortable i do worry
about okay what if we had a multi-year
recession but outside of that you could
only have stock prices trade
unsustainably low or high for so long
and then it breaks track isn't there a
worry of opportunity cost worth let's
say your money's tied up and like
corsair tattooed chef and and smile
direct that there's the opportunity cost
of these other companies that might do
better in the short term or at least
better over the next let's say one to
three years yeah so there's a there's a
few frames of mind from that one is do
you want to get caught up into making
short-term decisions right i'm always
trying to make the best decision over
the next three to five years that's
always my thought process going in
what's going on for this company over
the next three to five years past five
years i don't really know because that's
too far in the future and if i'm making
a bet for a year that's pretty darn
short term to be honest so i'm usually
thinking three to five years out when it
comes to these companies and um i'm
trying to make the best decision for the
long term when it comes to those and uh
you know back to the rest part of that
question uh you know what was that again
do you worry do i worry is it do you do
you have a concern for yourself or like
what what if these just keep falling oh
no no yeah i i i stay focused on long
term and then i just i look at the
fundamentals of underlying companies oh
and i remember the other point you know
you were kind of going across there what
if it was a better stock or something
like that right well what is that better
stock you know look at facebook after
hours today down 24 look what just
happened to paypal is that the better
stock that just went down 24 look what
happened to netflix netflix got slashed
24 on their earnings right and so you
know i i don't really um go into the
notion of you know oh maybe it'd be
better in these stocks or something like
that look at bank stocks a lot of those
are getting close to 52 week lows now
so i think in this sort of market you
got to stay with what you believe in for
the next three five years and and and
basically put blinders on for everything
else out there because i think it's just
you'll end up kevin o'leary today kevin
o'leary goes on cnbc he was a paypal
shareholder he got devastated in paypal
today it was down like 25
he says i'm done i'm selling paypal
today um putting the money in facebook
facebook goes down 25 after hours
so that's what like just ridiculous
moves people make in this sort of market
where they're just not thinking it's
like okay you just got slashed 25 on
paypal instead of buying the dip you're
gonna sell put that money in facebook
and facebook's just gonna slash 25
so um you know at the end of the day you
just have to put on blinders in this
sort of volatile market and stay focused
on the ones you like now you bought
paypal though
yes i bought paypal
yeah i was shocked to see it had dropped
more this morning yep and i bought a lot
more i put another 30 000 in this
morning 130. what did you buy
after hours yesterday i bought 15 000
then i bought another 15 000 as a drop
more and then i dropped another 15 15
000 as a drop more and then i put
another 30 000 in um this morning when
it was down low and my plan is if it
falls to 126 i'm gonna buy another
fifteen thousand if it falls to one
twenty one another fifteen thousand if
it goes all right let's get your cash
ready jeremy because jack's buying it
yeah i'm getting jacks immediately
tomorrow please do not buy paypal
this is going to be another robinhood
okay i don't even have any money anyways
that's good jack come on you why don't
you have any money jack tell us tell us
what's going on you spent it all in a
miata no i put it i put it all in robin
hood stock
thank you really jack i put a lot
how much did you buy around for like
fifteen thousand dollars
yeah
what do you mean that's not that'd be
worse that's a lot of money yeah i put a
lot in robin hood and uh i was wondering
i was like checking my banking i'm like
where is my money i don't know where it
is and i think what it where it went is
um a month or two ago i just like sent a
bunch of money to m1 finance okay yeah
and what would you do with m1 finance uh
well uh robin hood
no it's a it's a it's like a little bit
of tesla a little bit of amd and then
mostly like i think it's a vti and like
vug amd is looking good by the way
that's one of the very few stocks that's
holding up in this market yep so it my
m1 finance account is like okay but my
robin hood account is suffering
suffer suffering very badly very badly
yeah yeah now there's rumors paypal
might in the back half of this year if
robin hood and sofi continue to fall
they might try to make a move on robin
hood or so fight that's just a rumor
though we'll see
i cannot see robin hood being sold to
paypal i mean watch me eat my words
just
watch me a year from now someone will
take that clip
use it it'll it'll have happened i would
rather see like an apple i don't know
like an apple or like a google or like a
big a big five company swoop in take
them and then integrate them within like
a bigger service yeah robinhood might
need to like rebrand everything yeah
they need a big brother honestly yeah i
think if they got acquired by a bigger
company they changed the name they try
to make it a little bit different so
that way when people log in and they
they join they don't think of robinhood
yeah or they think of other new
companies they're trying to make these
changes yeah no that would that might
not be a bad idea at all
but the hood you guys still use the app
both of you or not anymore no okay i i
don't you know i still use it you still
use it okay yeah you have to admit
though for options
they're an easy platform for options
they make it they make it so simple and
margin too and margin and i still see i
still see on wall street bets people are
still posting robin hood screenshots wow
you're not seeing you're rarely seeing
them from any other brokerage so it goes
to show you i mean just how uh how
robinhood is being used right now yeah
options jeez man uh
by the way robin hood fell nine to nines
uh after hours that day reported and
today i think it's at 13 or 14. so it
made like a 30 40 jump like
a snap of fingers crazy
but um
but yeah nonetheless you know that's
kind of the way i think about the market
stay focused on the long term over the
next three five years this is a lot to
be scared of right now you got the fed
you got recession fears you got
companies not really giving guidance um
i think there's a lot to be scared of in
this time but uh you know the best the
best thing you could do is just focus on
the next three to five years so that's
kind of that's kind of my opinion on
that i find it surprising that you don't
panic or you don't get it all concerned
about stocks going down yeah
no um
i think it's just the experience that's
the thing um you know when you've been
doing it for so long i think that's what
it really comes down to
i think if you're a newer investor who's
just kind of started to get rolling in
this
i think i think it's very easy to get
panicked um you know i've held a lot of
stocks in my time that are very
controversial companies i've held a lot
of stocks that had huge short interest
i've held a ton of stocks i went down 20
30 40 on before so for me to go down in
stocks like that's expected i almost i
catch falling knives all the time
so you know think about some of the
stocks i've been in even in my youtube
career gopro which went obviously
dramatically bad right tesla which was
the first year i was investing that was
a drama show elon musk with the sec all
that um
obviously being through the crash
getting started in the crash been
through corrections i think i've just
been through so much that i think that's
what gives me the confidence to kind of
hold through but you also must have some
like personal practices that keep you so
level-headed and calm because every time
i i see you it doesn't matter like i i
oh i used to see you more often when i
lived with graham yeah but i every time
i still see you you're very calm and
collected what do you do in your own
personal life to stay so calm and
collected like do you like meditate do
you get like a good amount of sleep
every night what is it yeah so sleep yes
i always get six to eight hours every
night um i go to bed super late but then
i wake up kind of late so i might go to
bed at 2 00 a.m and usually wake up like
9 a.m maybe 10 a.m if i sleep in a
little bit so i always get a healthy
amount of sleep i meditate every day for
about 15 minutes before i go to bed um
that just that helps with like anxiety
and those sorts of things which i think
is something that you know in this sort
of market uh you need that right mindful
meditation helps massively with like
stress stress relief and anxiety and in
this sort of market we're in right now
there's a lot of stress and a lot of
anxiety i think that gets the best of
people um but at the end of the day like
i said i think a lot just goes back to
experience if you've been through it and
you've been going through it um and the
thing for me is i've been doing it so
long and i've just kind of climbed the
ranks it wasn't like i went from like
you know a super small amount of money
to like an ex like a huge amount of
money the first time i had six figures
in the stock market i was 23 years old
23 years old was six figures in the
stock market 24 i hit 200k in the stock
market and um you know then maybe 28 i
hit a million or so 28 29 so my my you
know kind of moves up as has been um i
would call it gradual whereas um you
know if you just flood in a bunch of
money let's say you're already a
millionaire and then you flood some
money in the market i think it's really
easy to get scared so but as far as me
those are some of the practices i
usually do when did you start meditating
i did that uh i started that let's see
that was about a year and a half ago
yeah i started meditation about a year
and a half ago and uh that was
definitely amazing you know i'm happy i
found mindful meditation because i
always was somebody that dealt with a
lot of anxiety and like over worrying
about things and those sorts of things
so um i came across mindful meditation
and my gosh that was a you know a life
changer i would say um because the
structure of your brain you can actually
change it i don't think a lot of people
realize this you can actually change the
way your your brain functions
and
i actually started diving i knew you
know i didn't even think about that i
thought like the way your brain is or
how you think is like just like how you
think right um but it's not it's like
just like you can transform your body to
be more strong or more fast or you know
get a six-pack or whatever you can do
the same thing with your brain and i
came across a wim hof method probably
three years ago and that's what started
me down this cycle of like you could
actually change your brain you could
change the way you think the way you
behave in those sorts of things and then
about a year and a half ago when i came
across mindful meditation and that was
kind of like the the next level of like
understanding uh how to strengthen your
brain and the science-based uh you know
advantages that is astronomical i would
say anybody watching this look into it
there's no hurt it will do to you and
it'll only help but first i'd like to
thank our sponsor vinovest alex i just
came up with the best investing idea
well what is it i'd like to buy wine let
it age and become more valuable and then
sell it for a profit the only problem is
i don't know where i would store the
wine or buy it or sell it i really don't
know anything about wine well jack with
vinovus you could do all of that without
worrying about a single thing and
vinoves is the best and easiest place to
invest in wine we always say
diversifying is the best way to grow
your portfolio and since wine has a very
low correlation with the stock market
it's perfect vinovest inspects every
bottle for authenticity then they store
it in a climate-controlled room and they
monitor them 24 7. think about it what
costs more a new or an aged bottle of
wine every year that wine ages it goes
up in value and that's exactly how every
other good investment works in the first
quarter of 2020 the dow in the s p 500
dropped a whole 22
and where did that leave wine up 1.1
percent don't liquidate your assets
liquefy them with vinovest
so check out the link down below in the
description and start diversifying your
portfolio today with vinovest guys check
out vinovus down below in the
description thank you vinovus for
sponsoring this episode and back to the
podcast walk us through the process how
did you learn about it and how do you do
that
how do you do what does it mean to
mindfully meditate mindful meditation
what it is essentially is you know
imagine you're you know i usually just
go to my closet in the dark and just sit
down and um what you do you close your
eyes and you know you're usually always
gonna be thinking thoughts right and
your job is essentially to focus back on
your breathing so you're gonna think
about something then you focus back on
your breathing focus on your breathing
your mind's gonna also drift from
thinking about breathing to thinking
about something else then it's you up
for you to say you know basically in
your head thoughts and then bring it
back to your breath work again um or
maybe you hear a sound in the house or
something happens and you process that
as sound
and then you start you know focusing on
your breathing again and so it's
training it's essentially like you would
train your body you're training your
brain to not over over obsess about
things that aren't relevant or whatnot
and understand you don't have to have
compulsive thoughts or something like
that so
that's something that it personally
helps me with it does help with focus as
well which is something i always had a
lot of trouble with uh in terms of
uh focusing on a conversation or
something like that that was something i
used to have a lot of trouble with and
i've noticed my focus has definitely
improved since i started mindful
meditation because you know there's a
lot of times where i would be there but
not really be there you know what i mean
like you're talking to somebody having a
conversation you're kind of like giving
the vibe like you're you're in that
conversation but you're not really in
that conversation and uh last thing i've
seen some improvement with is memory i
definitely can remember things better
than the past and everything's not as
much as a blur and i can remember
specific things i said to somebody or
specific things that happen which is
helpful because you know especially if
you're in a busy lifestyle you it can
start to just become like a blur and
you're like dude i can't remember what i
ate yesterday i can't remember what i
did
and um you know that's not a fun way to
live you know because then you're just
like oh my god why do i need to remember
what i ate yesterday yeah why do i need
to remember that like i don't know i
feel like my mind could go without those
little details yeah because then it's
like well you know i don't need to
retain that info but it's also about
like conversations you have with people
um meaningful things that that happen
being present that's a huge thing it
helped me be more present and like enjoy
like this sounds crazy but like little
stuff like birds chirping or whatever
like that's type of stuff
you know when you're when you're so
you're in your mind so like obsessed in
this this weird state you stop even
paying attention like nature and like uh
you know good things going on and
whatnot that uh us as humans i think
just crave and um you know so so anyways
there's been a lot that has changed for
me for the better and i would say
overall i'm happier and the reason i
think i'm mainly happier is because of
not having to worry about things
constantly and over obsessing over
whatever is going on or whatever what
were you worrying about previously oh my
gosh everything you know it didn't
matter if there's ever anything in my
life that went wrong um you know i would
i would just over obsess about thinking
about it constantly worry like oh my
gosh this could happen this could happen
this could happen um into a very
unhealthy state you know where you just
have obsessed obsessive thoughts about
things that are going to go wrong or
could go wrong this might go wrong you
know what if this happens i don't know
what if this this light falls on my head
and i die you know what i mean like it's
just ridiculous thoughts that don't even
make sense but you
you know i'm sure there's people out
there that have gone through that and
that's where you know i kind of reached
a breaking point i'm like i got to
figure out a way out of this and that's
how i came across mindful meditation i
was always heard about it but i never
really knew about it i heard about it i
was like uh i thought it was just some
some you know whatever thing you know
that some people do and i what got me
was i looked in the science-based facts
around it and what that because i was
like well if somebody says it's good
maybe they just it's in their brain that
like they're like oh that that helped me
out but when you look into the
science-based things that's what got me
into it and so yeah have you done that
jack mindful meditation
i tried meditating probably a month and
a half ago when i was doing it every
single day and i was like listening to
something too like a guide that would
walk me through it you know and i did
the the introductory course for it which
i think was like seven or ten days and i
then it came like oh you gotta pay and i
was like oh god
i stopped it was helping too
i don't know on youtube i don't know i i
should have just
youtube yeah yeah you're right i i tell
myself all the time probably every day
that i gotta get back into meditating
this is a sign i used to
and why'd you stop because it helped and
then i thought i was cured yes ah that's
a problem
mental health is just like physical
health and i think that's the way people
are going to start viewing in the future
i don't think that's the way it's been
viewed as a the past but just like you
know go in the gym right you could get
overweight and then you you go to the
gym and then you get down to like a
healthy weight and you're like oh i'm
feeling pretty good about myself but
then all of a sudden if you break it
you're going to gain that weight back so
same thing with like mental health if
you get yourself to a good point because
you're doing something you got to stay
strong and keep doing that thing
otherwise you'll end up relapsing and
you'll get into a weakened state again
and then your brain won't be in a good
place and so you gotta you gotta keep it
up if you wanna stay in good shape
that's why i look at it you kind of got
your physical shape and then you got
your mental shape so what do you think
led to you being so nervous and anxious
about random things do you think there
was something that happened or something
like growing up or maybe this is just
how this has just been you
since you were a child yeah i mean i
think probably my family circumstances
growing up um definitely could have uh
you know drove me to just be you know
have more anxiety as a kid i think some
of it's probably hereditary you know
like it's
you're born in certain ways right and so
i think some people are are more likely
to um you know have those anxiety type
thoughts than than other folks maybe
whereas other folks just you know
that doesn't even hit them they don't
worry about anything you got some people
that are fearless right like they don't
get scared of anything they don't fear
anything they don't have any anxiety and
they're just kind of like naturally like
that like they don't even need to try
and you got other folks that that really
had problems with that so um you know i
think some of it's just probably
lifestyle growing up and i think part of
it's just maybe maybe the way i am you
know and do you think it's partially
that anxiety and that like nervousness
that led you to like want to do so much
with your life and like become like a
multi-millionaire and like achieve great
things i i don't think so um
first off i'm a scorpio so if you don't
know about scorpios look them up okay
look them up
look them up sometime okay but uh yeah i
think for me you know i just love i love
competition i love competing um i love
playing games i love winning and losing
jack you know this because we play
tennis many times and you know i can get
very very competitive and i just love
that and even if you beat me like i'm
like okay you know i would rather
compete and lose to you than not play at
all and so for me money is kind of a you
know it's it's a game you know it's a
fun game and that's kind of the way i
look at it and there's certain things
i'm trying to do in my life obviously
like i'd love to be able to make crazy
amounts of money to give it back to
charity and things like that not just
give it to my kids so they can ride
around on yachts or something like that
but that's kind of that's kind of the
way i think and i'm like you know uh to
me it's just very motivating you know i
think that's i love business i love
investing i love those sorts of things
it's not like it doesn't even feel like
work for me i listened to a conference
call in the bubble bath last night you
know it doesn't it doesn't doesn't
bother me
bubble bath yeah bubble is that another
trick i i take at least uh two to three
baths a week yeah do your bubble bath
yeah on a conference call that's awesome
yeah mm-hmm yeah
is it just to you uh usually yeah yeah
usually sometimes
[Laughter]
some nice romantic music and very white
in the background nice
nice so yeah
[Laughter]
there's a reason i have three kids you
know what i mean oh wow
wow that's fine
so yes being with you just had a third
child yes indeed yep number three uh
baby axel so
how did you pick that how did you pick
the name axel
uh well so we tried to come up with
somewhat creative names for all the kids
and so um
i don't know we were just thinking and
then we came across that name and we're
like oh that that's that's pretty
different like how many people you know
they're named that and we're trying to
think of a four letter name because the
other kids have four letter names as
well so that's how we came up with that
but yeah i didn't think i would be a
father of three so i didn't picture that
in my life i also started having kids
way younger than i thought i thought
i would probably start having kids in my
30s that's how i really thought and then
i ended up having you know
one kid at 24. one kid at 20 was a seven
and then obviously this one a little
late for jack that would be in a year
from now that's that's crazy imagine in
one year i could not wait
24 when the baby was born
yes 24 yep yeah so actually jack that
would mean like now
yeah so you started she was pregnant
when i was 23. wow yep see i can't i
cannot imagine taking care of a child or
like a pregnant wife right now that
would just be like so much for me yeah i
think
i think people make it out to be a lot
bigger than it is in their heads like oh
my gosh i'm not ready for that i'm not
ready for that and it's not as big of a
deal as you think i think it's a pretty
big deal it's not it's not i think i
think especially as men i don't think
and even women are like this i think
you know i don't think you ever feel
like you're ready i'll be clear about
that there's never going to be a time
point where it's like oh i feel ready to
have kids now it just doesn't work like
that um
you know you'll never feel fully ready
you always feel a little unconfident
because it's it's a big responsibility
it's like i'm bringing somebody into
this world i've got to try to keep them
on the right track i got to try to teach
them all this stuff and whatnot so it's
a huge responsibility but you'll ne in
my opinion you'll never feel ready um
you just got to do it and and then when
it's there you're like oh my gosh it's
like the best thing ever so
um you know i yeah i could i could say
confidently i look at bag of my life you
know my wife and i talk about this
sometimes it's like what did we do
before we had kids like life like when i
look back i'm like man that's so boring
like what do we do like go out to eat or
something like you know what i mean and
then once you have kids it's like
there's so much fun they can get
annoying sometimes but there's so much
fun that it's like uh your whole life
changes and and uh yeah it's enjoyable
so but you'll never feel like you're
ready i'll just i'll just put that out
there so
[Music]
yeah
interesting
all right let's let's keep it going tell
us about the hungry bullet journal oh oh
my god with that kid yeah yes
give a background on the hungry bullet
because this has been a long time in the
works and it's been draining a lot of
money oh my gosh
you've been making a lot of videos on
your money losing company oh i gotta get
back to that i haven't been doing that
thanks for reminding me yeah so
basically you take a pile of money and
you burn it yes that's exactly basically
it the bowl is hungry okay uh yeah so
hungry bowl you know we came across that
concept i don't know maybe sometime
around this time last year roughly
around doing a newsletter then we built
it into an app got the app launched um
in august about august and uh it was
really rough at that time but
people stayed with us we just continued
to improve and improve it and uh man
it's been a lot of work i could tell you
that it's a lot of work you know if
anybody was thinking about starting an
app or or anything like that it is so
much work to try to make this thing
successful
um a lot of people have been putting in
a lot of time and um you know we're
making progress but you know
it's definitely not just like uh i think
i maybe was a little naive going in i
think if i if i
i think if i knew what i know now i
wouldn't have done it i'll be honest um
but with that being said sometimes
ignorance is the best thing ever right
because
if you know what you're kind of in for
you're much more likely to be like ah
nah forget that and that you never push
through to reach something right
kind of like youtube youtube i put out a
hundred videos uh and i maybe had a
thousand subscribers a hundred videos if
i knew i was going to put in that much
work and get that little out of it i
think my first year on youtube i made
like a thousand bucks maybe max
um and so same thing with the hungry
bowl i went in i think very very uh you
know ignorant in this situation and i
thought oh you know
this is we're gonna make this work it's
gonna be you know a year from now we're
going to be at this incredible place and
i'm just like it takes a lot longer to
build things out the way you want to
build a mount it's tough you got to keep
people motivated
developers are so in demand right now
it's incredible
and
they have all the power right now and so
yeah it's it's a grind it's something i
committed to for five years so i'm still
staying with it five years yeah yeah why
why five years well i did understand
going in it was not going to be
i i didn't know it was going to be this
hard but i also understood it wasn't
going to happen like tomorrow like you
look at almost everything that's you
know been successful it usually takes
time to really get it up to a level um
that it's it's doing great right and
it's in a great place if we even think
about our youtube channels like the
first year definitely wasn't a great
place right uh year two things start to
really click you're three okay now now
it's really starting to get going so
it's the same exact way i looked at the
hungry bowl i'm like the first year is
going to be really rough you know um
year two hopefully you start to make
some progress and like okay we're
getting somewhere with this thing and
then year three hopefully is that year
where you're like okay we're doing this
like and so this year for me and i told
the guys this i said if we make it
through this year we're good uh we're
gonna be on the way as long as we make
it through this year um
but yeah i mean it's a it's a lot of
work we grind on it thank you to
everybody that ever supports hungry bull
uh we appreciate you guys we got uh
hopefully a website coming at some point
this year and hopefully just gonna make
the app better and better and thank you
everybody that leaves us a review on the
app store it means a lot it means a lot
um we're trying to do something special
there and there was a guy i i heard
earlier who spent five billion dollars
in the uk to build that a stock
brokerage wow five billion dollars how
much they've spent so far
and i'm thinking to myself five billion
you may as well like what's the point of
building the brokerage it's like you
spend five billion so you could get five
billion i'm like you already have five
bills yeah exactly don't build a
brokerage that's chill insane five
billion dollars oh my gosh wild geez i
don't even know how that's possible yeah
i have kind of an interesting uh
proposition okay so you said that you
kind of suffered with like anxiety and
nervousness and stuff like that yeah and
i know that graham has something that's
similar
and i'm wondering i have a step tight
that's all
you have a video on youtube titled my
struggle with social anxiety not anymore
but i thought i came you know you solved
it i saw
you just practice putting yourself out
there right got it well i i have a
theory and i think
disproportionately a lot of people that
are very successful struggle from
anxiety and being nervous and stuff like
that and because of that it pushes them
to achieve more because they want they
have either like a scarcity mentality or
they just somehow feel inferior and feel
like they need to compensate by being
successful financially yeah what do you
guys think about that
um sounds like something a broke person
was saying
[Music]
no
yeah i mean i don't really have any
thoughts about that i think different
things drive different people to be
honest um you know i can't speak for
other people but i know for just me
personally you know i love business and
investing so much you know like ever
since i really started to dive into it
when i was in college you know it was
just something that like right away like
i always hated school i was a horrible
student i graduated high school with a
2.23 gpa 2.23 so for those who don't
know that's very bad okay
and um you know and and then i go i go
to community college and i start taking
like business courses and whatnot and i
started getting like a's and b's and i i
just i always enjoyed it even like
accounting which accounting is is a
subject that you know i think a lot of
people do not like you know reading
income statements balance sheets cash
flows those sorts of things right and
doing accounting for companies i took
three levels of that
and i thought that was fun i think
because at the end of the day it came
down to money and it was like business
related and so i even found accounting
fund where i nev i always hated anything
math related right um in school like
that was one of my worst subjects but i
enjoyed it so much and so for me it was
kind of like i just found that as a
passion and uh i've always been obsessed
with business and investing ever since
and i'm always very obsessed with like
anybody who's very successful at
anything i was just a great appreciation
for people that are really on top of
their game you know where they're like
they're the best at their craft i love
sports and like uh you know i always
love watching tiger woods play golf i
don't even like golf but like how
dominant he was back in the day or you
know any of these athletes tom brady and
whatnot it's like i just appreciate
anybody that's that great at something
so and graham on youtube how great he is
you know we just appreciate him he's in
the hall of fame so
but uh yeah that's kind of my thoughts
on that so i don't know if you have any
thoughts there graham yeah no i agree
i've always been obsessed though with
like uh with with saving and and money
and investing so i've always been
gravitating towards that uh even as a
young age i'd collect like i would look
through the change and i i and i knew
that my grandpa told me there's a 1909
svdb penny and those pennies were worth
like two thousand dollars and i'd look
through all the pennies at like six
years old to try to find that 1909 svdb
penny you're not you're never gonna find
one but but just in case it was there
and i'd like collect when the state
quarters came out remember those yep i
collected i loved this date yeah i had i
collected all of them and i tried and i
would keep the ones that were in the
best condition
and i had that book uh that little thing
where you squeeze them in there like in
all 50 states i loved that was it
collecting in general or collecting
money
because it was money both
both i think i love collecting things
but i also like collecting things of
value that will keep their value or
increase in value what i'm curious is
what do you think is in you that makes
you want to collect things and like save
is there anything in you or is it just a
raw desire you just like it i used to be
a squirrel in a past life just uh
finding nuts and just burying them away
i don't know i just i love i love
collections i love when i see someone's
collection no matter what it is because
it's cool
to see like the piece something together
and keep it in good condition and i
don't know something about it this is
neat
no i can understand that i had a great
business when i was six years old seven
years old it was a legal gambling
business so i had a i had a bingo little
machine and uh my dad and my brother
they always loved gambling on anything
so i'd run this little uh machine and
play bingo against him and that was a
pretty profitable business i gotta say
that was one of my most profitable
businesses i ever had oh so
i used to have one of those as a as a
kid it was a it was a toy but it was
like this this plastic gambling thing
like a slot machine oh and you would do
the thing like you put in a quarter you
do the thing and if you got all sevens
it would it would displace all the
quarters that were put in there
and i go to my grandma's house and i put
it up there and sometimes we'd have
family over and i would ask everyone to
like try to win money and i just collect
the quarters yeah i remember one time i
think somebody won and oh god all the
quarters i was so upset
i was like no no no that didn't work you
got to do it again it glitched wasn't
supposed to do that oh my gosh yeah yeah
no
and then that brought me another point
you know as my childhood i was
introduced to gambling very very young
you know because of my my dad and my
brother and
you know even as a little kid we go the
dog track which i don't know if you guys
ever been to a dog track before it's uh
basically greyhounds race around and try
to catch this little electronic bunny
and whoever whatever dogs win i don't i
don't even know if it's legal nowadays i
don't know
it might yeah peta might not be no way
yeah i know the one that they we used to
go to called i think was called
greyhound park in phoenix i think they
closed it down long long time ago but i
was introduced to that at a very young
age and so i think that's where i get
kind of my my uh
like understanding of risk right from a
very very young age because i was
introduced to gambling and like
understanding like that's too much risk
to take or that's the right amount of
risk and what i used to bet on as a
little kid is i don't have my dad place
at bets or whatever is i would bet on
dogs to show which to show means you
come in the top three it's seen as like
a safer bet you don't win as much money
but it's a little safer so versus
betting out a dog to win because i think
there was either eight or ten dogs in
the race and you know you never know
who's going to win out of those dogs
so reminds me why you like so much that
we have this horsey game yeah
that's funny that's funny i love the
horsey game you just want to and i i'll
admit it's so much fun so very fun it's
i never thought i'd enjoy this game so
much but it's like uh it's this
racetrack of horses and you click the
button and all these mechanical horses
run around the track and you don't know
which one is going to win
and i think there's yeah like eight of
eight eight or ten of them and they all
have different odds and you click the
ones that you think are gonna win yeah
and sometimes it'll be neck and neck and
then all of a sudden like the one in the
last place will go like zoom in front of
everyone else's last minute you're like
oh one was winning and then three just
took over yeah the last second oh yeah
no
and you know we were always uh you know
being around my dad my brother was eight
years older than me they're always
gambling on something man always sports
betting uh you know uh doing that type
of stuff or we even used to gamble on
video games so we used to have a horse
racing game there was a video game for
playstation 2 i think it was back in the
day and uh we would they would give you
odds in the game and we had this little
box that you'd put money into to bet on
your horse coming in a certain place and
if you lost in the money state in the
box it was like this little bank uh box
and uh so yeah i think i think at the
end of the day like i was so around so
much gambling that i got very
comfortable with taking risk in like
where is my calculated risk
at that i should take and where should i
not take risk so i think that's another
reason why i don't freak out in the
market because
i mean when you're gambling you know you
lose a bet you lose 100 of your money if
if i go down 20 or 30 on the stock it
doesn't really freak me out so
as long as my companies don't go
bankrupt i should be okay so
[Laughter]
why don't you take 10 to your portfolio
and just
invest that in some of the riskier plays
because it would give you a different
aspect to talk about with a smaller
portion of your portfolio what do you
mean
mercier plays like this to your stocks
like more i don't want to say momentum
but uh but you know i don't say gambling
yeah but
you know some of the hypeier stocks that
uh
you know
in short-term plays oh yeah under a year
but between one and five months yeah so
short-term plays first off some of the
stocks i'm in people would see as
riskier because some of the stocks i'm
in are unprofitable businesses right now
in high growth in newer companies um so
i think some stocks i am in including
tattoo chef i think some people would be
like that's a high-risk business so i
definitely don't think i'm in the safest
stocks possible
but i think you go down a dangerous path
if you're trying to do short-term stuff
like try to swing in and out of stocks
and things like that even if it's with a
smaller amount of money it leads you to
doing that more and more often which is
something i got caught in 2015 where
you kind of end up in this bad cycle of
dominoes where it's like oh i'm making
this move and i'm making this move and
you start getting in and out of the
market you start getting more in and out
of positions and ultimately in the stock
market i try to just stay focused
because the more i do that i know i'm
not good at that i'm not good at trading
most people aren't like 98 people i'm
not good at trading i'm not successful
at swing trading that's not my thing
every time i ever do that i lose money
and when i say lose money i don't mean
like you go down for a little bit and
then you make it back i mean you like
lose or lose money right you buy um a
call option in a stock because you think
their earnings are going to be good and
it doesn't happen you lose 100 of your
money and so i think it's just a
dangerous game that i'm not really
willing to play so that's why i try to
stay away from that because i think you
you get into a real bad cycle when it
comes to got it
i'm also curious what is in the private
account
oh the private portfolio yeah it's uh
pretty much all the same stocks you know
of tattoo chef's my biggest which uh
tattooed chef let's see
between the so i think in the public
account i'm up to like maybe 20 000
shares of tattoo chef and the private
account it might have like 65 000. so i
think between those two accounts i'm up
to like 85 000 shares of taxes 65 000
and what's what's tattooed chef at so 65
000 times
yeah i don't know a million yeah yeah
roughly a million in the chef and um so
you know a lot of those are the same
type of stocks honest i've been buying
honest a lot i probably have uh
i don't know three or four hundred
thousand in honest right now um and then
obviously i got some uh
plays that i don't have in the main like
stc
um
paypal i just started buying in that one
i already got 72 in in paypal now so but
a lot of it's just uh you know the same
type of stocks i don't the one stock i
don't own in my my private account is
tesla that's the one stock i don't own
that i do own in the public i um
i cashed tesla a while back and when oh
i can't remember but it was it was uh
it's higher than when i sold that's what
i know for sure um i looked at it and i
was kind of like well
i could take a little risk off the table
i was a little test tesla heavy at that
time i felt like and so uh cached a
little bit but yeah it was a bad
decision usually it's a bad decision to
sell tesla i usually always regret it
and i've cashed out shares of the public
account over time too and every time
why sell in the private but not in a pub
but it sounds like you sold in both
yeah in in the
in terms of my private if i recall i
always held less so it was less to sell
uh in the public account now down to 500
shares of tesla which i know still
probably sounds like a lot but um
yeah that one that one i've cashed out
of two the thing that kind of worries me
and this kind of frustrates me with
tesla and is kind of the battle of your
mind right is i'm trying to stay focused
on the long term with tesla but what i
do worry about is i'm like i'm like man
are they really
what if we were to go into a recession
right are people really going to be out
there buying 50 000 60 000
teslas and because tesla is starting to
get to bigger and bigger numbers they're
going to become more and more like an
auto company in terms of trying to hit
numbers and if people aren't
really excited to buy cars because let's
say we're at a bad economic time what
does it mean for tesla's numbers right
so
these are kind of like conflicting
things you have to go through in the
stock market where it's like okay i'm
trying to stay focused on the long term
of tesla but it trades at a super high
pe and what if we were to go into a
recession and
we're in a situation where uh you know
people just aren't buying cars so
you know but at the end of the day a lot
of times what i found is
selling
tassel is just usually my
mistake as funny as it sounds and when i
got a lot of crap because when i was
buying in tesla back in the day
i actually had sold completely out of my
apple stock back then and i put my apple
stock into tesla stock which apple
stock's done amazing since then tesla
did obviously much better
and so whenever i've sold out tesla
shares recently i've been putting that
money into the chef and some of these
other stocks and people look at that and
they're like what are you doing man
you're gonna sell it out of tesla to put
some money in that stock like that's
ridiculous and i can understand why
people think that um you know and we'll
see what what's the right decision over
time but yeah most of the time i've ever
sold any tesla shares i usually always
regret it so
how much is in the private group if you
paid me
one hundred thousand dollars
i would tell you
but not even ninety nine thousand
dollars what if you wanna imagine it's
like a thousand dollars yeah
what's your net worth right now
uh went down
all of ours did man 55 million that's
like it's like 15 now but it was at the
peak it was 16 five
uh or like sixteen eight and then i had
to pay taxes which bumped it down plus
the market went down
so it's like fifty
it's like fifteen now okay
yeah that's a nice number yeah well you
you you make videos about that too it
went from 16 to 2
down to 14 4. oh with the low take a
screenshot now i don't want to take a
screen i want to take a stream just use
that just use that and then the market
dropped on top of that so
uh 14 5.
yeah well man nasdaq is going to be
rough tomorrow the net worth is going to
go down more man i hate to break the
news to you so
but anyways um
yeah so
i don't know man do you want to do you
want to play our little game yeah let's
play a game okay let's play a game right
yeah all right so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna pretend we have a five
million dollar portfolio and we each
have to pick
uh five stocks and then we're gonna when
we're done we're gonna tape it to the
bottom of this table and next time it
comes on whenever that is we'll pull it
out and we'll we'll you know talk about
the stocks and then we'll put it back
and then next time we'll come on we'll
do it again cool so all right
uh we need a million dollars in each
stock so first one um two million no
yeah paypal is the first one i'm picking
here p-y-p-l
i think that's 131 dollars here today
i'm putting a million in that okay i'm
picking the chef you know i wasn't going
to do this without a good old ttcf and
that's uh 12 and some change
uh let's see honest honest
so h and
st
uh that should be six think i'm gonna go
with the planet okay uh planet couldn't
see that one coming you couldn't see it
last one
oh corsair gaming
i'm not gonna pick corsair just because
you want me to pick corsair i'm actually
gonna pick sdc which is sdc what's to
that today guys 270
270 290.
so i'm gonna have a good mix here and
jack all right you look like you're
scheming over there
so i'm definitely i'm definitely doing
google oh google mcdougall that is
pre-split oh man i'm gonna be boring i'm
gonna do apple too
and can we also include crypto
oh
yes we should be able to okay i'll let
you guys do it all right i think i don't
like that yeah i'll do ethereum
yours is gonna be very similar to mine i
got three stocks so then i'm gonna do
spy uh and then i'll do
why not bitcoin bitcoin that is what's
bitcoin at jack 30 38.
all right jack
all you
boy
pressure's on all right
first stock on
apple
apple okay
oh ours is so similar graham oh my god
i'm also picking goose this is what uh
this is what jack does he just copies my
trades
and then everything he buys just goes
down oh my gosh like clockwise we
already know
like i'm i'm worried about writing down
my stocks because jack's to me they can
be like well i'm not gonna buy that i
could buy that i could buy that i'm
gonna put ethereum
oh geez now ethereum's gonna crash
thanks jack
i'm gonna put robin hood oh the hood
okay i i appreciate that jack at least
that's sticking your head out there for
a bit
i appreciate it that's gonna be the one
wild card is robin hood yeah i
appreciate it i would be shocked if
they're trading lower than they are
today but
yeah they got the problem with them they
got two more tough quarters to go
through two more really tough comps oh
gosh facebook are you gonna buy facebook
tomorrow no i'm actually not why their
their numbers were so bad
that even i don't want to buy the dip in
that one tomorrow which is saying a lot
but this is this is taking them back to
basically where they were at the peak
before
covet yeah but dude the numbers are so
bad so um it's bad bad bad amd okay wow
119. i i remember it was at like 130.
119. okay 0.69
okay 29.69 dang okay you know what i
think the issue with facebook is is that
everyone they basically got the entire
planet to sign up yeah like how many
more like now the only new people
signing up are like just have to be born
like they have to they have to like in
new york new people born don't want to
sign right facebook and that's the thing
then there's so then they would rather
spend time on tick tock so i think
they've already got everyone that they
could yeah and so the only way is to
expand on that is to either buy other
companies who have a younger demographic
or they could try to advertise to the
existing audience more but
but yeah i mean i don't know i feel like
it's just it's an older demographic on
facebook and i think they just care
about they want the millennial audience
yeah and instagram still does well but
the problem is instagram reels is doing
really good but they don't make that
much money off instagram is instagram
reels actually doing well yeah for them
it's doing well i don't think it's doing
as well as tick tocks doing but it's
doing well they specifically cited that
but they don't make hardly any money off
instagram reels compared to how much
they make off feed
and those sorts of things youtube needs
to figure out their youtube shorts
because they're getting better with the
algorithm but still tick tock's
algorithm is so on it and i hate to say
it but it does feel like people are just
re like they're taking the tick tocks
and then just
slap it in youtube yeah slap it
instagram yeah um
youtube really needs to i think if
youtube were smart they would pay
creators for exclusivity they're only
going to create content for a year on
youtube shorts and pay a ridiculously
good point because youtube could
probably afford it yeah they could
easily yeah if they paid their top
creators and we say hey we'll pay you a
million dollars a year
only post on youtube but i think a lot
of tick tock isn't like the same
creators getting a ton of views i think
like more people getting i think a lot
of tick tock is just like the
overwhelming amount of people that just
like are posting random stuff like
random people and say some funny viral
moment happens over here then it gets
traction on tick tock that's the way it
seems because i i mean i don't follow
that many people on tick tock but it to
me it seems like i'm more so just
getting shown the the funniest bits
posted in the last five days regardless
of who it's from it doesn't seem as
though the top creators like like on
youtube the more subscribers you have
usually you get the majority of the
views but imagine if youtube were just
divvied up on whoever has the most
retention that day
yeah like that's the video you're shown
yep and just maximizes the time that you
stuck to your phone i think that's a
little more older school uh youtube like
old old school youtube when it was just
kind of more of a free-for-all before
people were really focusing on building
channels out and things like that and
then after that then youtube pivoted
toward um like whoever had the most
subscribers really uh you got like a
dominant kind of feed before they went
to the algorithm right which i know the
algorithm frustrated a lot of people uh
when they actually moved to that and
like your homepage could be whatever
you know the algorithm thinks is
relevant to you so that's probably just
a stage tic talks app but
you know it's interesting seeing the
facebook numbers and their guidance
seeing google youtube kind of not uh be
impressive i think tick tock is
definitely a real serious competitive
threat to actually it absolutely is
because tick tock has figured out how to
keep people on the platform for longer
and again i look at i look at what
macy's doing and when she's brushing her
teeth
watching tick tock not youtube every now
and then she'll watch youtube but when
it's the majority of the time it's tick
tock and i see
it's i you know what i think it is it's
the the swiping i think tinder figured
it out that people like to sit on the
phone they like to be kind of engaged
like with that swiping feature but with
videos and they've combined that with
like the best of the videos that keep
people watching the longest and when you
have so much content on there the
algorithm can like pick and choose
it's wild graham what's something you
think jeremy can work on
it's probably a long list let me start
writing them and what is something that
you see in jeremy that you admire
okay so what jeremy could work on i
think is the uh the
i think the aesthetic
of the brand the channel the hungry bowl
i think all of that could be upgraded
and i think it's holding you back i
think when you look
at all the youtube channels with over a
million subscribers they have a good set
and i think that's really really really
important
and yours with the webcam and the little
upper hand side
the new viewers to your channel
it doesn't it doesn't bode uh
like sophistication
when they see that as a first impression
so i would say if you built out a good
set finally 10k just it doesn't have to
be too over the top like 10 000 in a
really nice set with a really good
camera
and you upload like that i bet it would
be the difference like filming the
millennial monies live
versus the podcast and and you see that
you know just steady subscribing then
just a big bump i think you would see
the same thing in your channel oh that's
good i think everything you could you
could double your views with a good set
oh that's good to know just good
aesthetics across the board yeah yeah
yeah i appreciate that what do i admire
jeremy's never stressed out i've never
seen it i've never seen jeremy anxious
stressed
uh
very much just zen i like that okay oh i
appreciate that thanks what about you
jack what can i work on man
um
i would i would i would actually agree
with graham i think it's just like the
the professionalism and i mentioned this
when we were driving your tesla i'm like
dude jeremy you really need to get a
better quality camera better quality
audio uh i think that would all go a
very long ways and i think realistically
it could if you spend you know five
thousand that's all you need to spend
yes five thousand dollars on a good
camera good mic and maybe just like
curtains for a backdrop that's it and
just like a wooden table uh i think
you'd probably make that money yeah i
was just thinking this would do really
well for you is um like those
what's the unboxing channel unbox their
was it unbox therapy where it's
basically just a table
with a not a green screen it's like a
gray screen in the back
with some lights shining up you're at
the table with your computer a few
little trinkets
that would be the easiest set imaginable
you get the headlight here you get some
lighting around here and it's as simple
as literally going over flicking on a
camera and done
i think it would probably make its money
back in like a month easy a few videos
yeah i i would say within the problem is
it's a lot of work no it's not i feel
like you could outsource it to someone
and pay someone like 3 000 a month and
they would take care of all that stuff
they could even probably edit for you
yeah it slows down speed doesn't matter
i don't know it does not matter
i think this is holding you back
massively yeah when you see how much
work because you're putting in this work
on your channel and you're getting a
small roi compared to what you could get
otherwise
it's like imagine someone clicking on
one of your videos and they've never
seen you before and the first thing that
comes up is like your desktop mm-hmm i'm
clicking out of that um
you can't com compete with like andre
who like makes his video
welcome back
and it's like everything and magic and
just the flipping cards and just crazy
editing he's talking about a high level
concept
uh
and andre is getting like 300 500 000
views of video yeah you're you're
putting in the same amount of education
between you and him it's just the the
video itself i think needs to be a
little more produced just slow down
editing but for the work you put in
you'll get 10 times more than you're
than you're currently getting yeah
i mean i have a little different view
and i do appreciate that and i i don't
think it's a bad idea um but i mean that
kind of changes the brand you know those
are very scripted videos like andre puts
in incredible script work um that would
change up you know my whole thing you
know in terms of like you have to do
that massive amount of script work you
have to spend massive amounts of time uh
filming kevin's not scripted
no i know so you could do that you you
could do the same thing that's what i'm
talking about it's flipping on the
camera but it's it's nicer it's it's not
your desktop but you're also talking
about like slowing things down like
andre you know and those sorts of things
so i'm like that's a whole different i
think just a little bit of a set a high
quality camera a nice mic would go a
long way what do you think something is
that that graham could work on and what
is something you admire graham for oh
that's a good question uh let's think
work on um i'm trying to make people
change the world be personal too it
doesn't have to be yeah it doesn't have
to be no no no um as far as work on let
me think i think
just um
kind of expanding outside of just
youtube and i think that's something you
have been trying to work on um i think
that's kind of the big thing you've got
such a really successful youtube thing
going right you know between all the
different channels so i think kind of
expanding outside of that i think would
be really really important
um
you know something i admire is just the
consistency you know and the work uh i
don't know a lot of people that like um
you know like really work like that you
know and and do it for years and years
and so i always look at you as somebody
that i know is working all the time and
i love you know living living next door
because i always know you're working and
you always know i'm working and so um
that's cool because i think there's a
lot of people that get uh very
complacent once they get to a certain
amount whether that's like two million
dollars or five million dollars or
whatever i think a lot of people get
very very complacent and so i've just
always appreciated that you you keep
grinding and you keep working and you're
not satisfied so
that's something i honestly really
admire in a big way so um you know i
respect like everybody that keeps keeps
it going once they have it because not
everybody does it so
thank you yeah absolutely and then jack
you know as far as you you don't need
anything you don't need to work on a
thing jack you're awesome
you shouldn't man oh jack wants to
outsource his perfectness yeah someone
else could be pregnant for jack and he
could hire it out wow yeah i've heard
you've been expanding your empire yeah
impressive it's nice it's nice it's good
stuff it's good stuff as long as you're
growing that's all that matters yeah
that's all that matters so you're going
to have more workers than graham's going
to have soon
i might already yeah
jack already no i don't i don't quite
yet i got alex but uh jack has like two
people already two or three you're a
tycoon man beast
i don't know what they do but you know
what just stuff man
it's good for you to know it's yeah i'm
helping him
unemployment is low because of jack
because this guy right here he's hiring
everybody oh gosh that's awesome man
that's awesome okay graham do you have
anything other other questions anything
other to mention jeremy here you think
there's anything else we should touch on
that maybe uh no i i think uh you know a
lot of people are curious about a
recession if we're gonna have a
recession or something like that i hate
to end it on a damper but uh you know i
think there's i think there's a lot to
be concerned about there's a lot of
companies right now that are not giving
guidance so a lot of companies are very
confused on what's gonna happen out
there and uh mr jay pal he's i think
he's even confused so we'll see how many
actual rate hikes i put my head out
there recently and i said i'd be amazed
if the fed raises more than twice this
year everybody's saying four to seven
times no i agree with you oh wow that's
a not many people think like that right
now but with all the cloudiness i think
it's uh
i think it's going to make it hard for
the fed to raise in meaningful ways
unless unless all of a sudden in the
back half of this year all the companies
are like oh everything's great then they
might raise but outside of that is there
you know i don't know they might be a
little more timid so
but yeah that's about it so
stay tuned to see what happens on the
next episode of is there gonna be a
recession
is jeremy gonna have another child stay
tuned and subscribe we'll link to your
channel down below in the description
and you can get your free stock as well
when you sign up for public use the good
gram
jeremy yeah thank you so much absolutely
thank you to public and uh wait i'm not
getting any money off that wait a minute
don't take it to publix
but anyways guys we got the paper we
have right under here okay it's going to
stay saved until next time i come on and
other than that uh by the dip
buy the drip guys
jack